la primera ley de newton nos dice que un
objeto que está en reposo o de hecho más
en general que un objeto que se
encuentra con la velocidad constante
entonces se mantendrá así a menos de que
se vea afectado por una fuerza neta que
sea desbalanceada ok entonces si tenemos
una velocidad constante la única forma
de mover o de de provocar que este
objeto pierda esa velocidad constante y
por supuesto cuando decimos velocidad
constante puede ser que su velocidad
constante sea cero lo cual implicaría
que está en reposo así que decir que
está en velocidad constante justamente
se refiere a que esté en reposo o en
movimiento uniforme y rectilíneo ok
entonces la única forma en que podemos
mover es un objeto que se encuentre a
velocidad constante o más bien quitarle
esa propiedad de que tenga la velocidad
constante sería si le aplicamos una
fuerza externa
digamos que está desbalanceada porque a
lo mejor podemos aplicar una fuerza por
la izquierda y una fuerza por la derecha
magnitud y se cancelan entonces eso no
está desbalanceado ahora bien la
pregunta natural que nos queda es bueno
si nosotros le imprimimos una fuerza a
algo que tiene una velocidad constante
como cambia ese objeto y eso lo responde
la segunda ley de newton que según yo es
como de las más famosas o bueno vamos a
dejarlo que es una ley muy famosa sobre
todo por cómo se expresa matemáticamente
entonces eso lo responde la segunda ley
de newton muy bien la segunda ley de
newton que se refiere también al
movimiento y lo que nos dice la segunda
ley de newton es esta fórmula muy famosa
que la fuerza le voy a poner aquí bien
su flechita porque esta es unidad
vectorial es igual a la masa del objeto
la masa del objeto por la aceleración
por la aceleración entonces como puedes
darte cuenta la fuerza es una unidad
vectorial ya que la aceleración lo es
muy bien y la verdad es que es bastante
bastante interesante y muy bonito ver
cómo todas las leyes del universo que al
menos servían hasta antes de que éste
apareciera se escribían en términos
matemáticos muy simples entonces vamos a
vamos a ver qué es lo que nos está
diciendo la segunda ley de newton
imaginemos que tenemos un bloque en el
espacio digamos ok digamos que tenemos
un bloque en el espacio
que le aplicamos una fuerza ne está
desbalanceada aunque digamos aquí le
aplicamos esta este este vector digamos
que es una fuerza le aplicamos una
fuerza en esta dirección esto me está
diciendo la segunda ley de newton que la
fuerza que lee o más bien la aceleración
que va a provocar una fuerza va a ser
proporcional con lo dije al revés que la
fuerza que le aplicamos es proporcional
a la aceleración que provoca entonces
esta aceleración va a ir en la misma
dirección que la fuerza que le
imprimimos por supuesto que tan grande o
chico es este vector pues dependerá de
nuestra constante de proporcionalidad
que es justamente esta m eso es lo que
nos está diciendo que la fuerza es
proporcional a la aceleración y la
constante de proporcionalidad es lo que
conocemos como masa la masa del objeto y
no hay que confundir
la masa con peso de hecho voy a hacer un
vídeo en específico para aclarar la
diferencia entre masa y peso digamos que
en términos sencillos vamos a dejarlo
por ahorita así la masa mide qué tanta
materia tiene un cuerpo aunque entonces
la masa por supuesto solo depende del
cuerpo mientras que el peso es la fuerza
que se le imprime a ese objeto por
efectos de la gravedad aunque ya
entonces la masa es una propiedad del
objeto mientras que la el peso depende
de la gravedad en donde sea la gravedad
que se imprime sobre este sobre este
objeto por ejemplo no es el mismo peso
aquí en la tierra que en la luna muy
bien entonces lo bonito de esto es que
está en términos muy sencillos por
ejemplo no tenemos que la fuerza es
igual a la masa cuadrada por la raíz
cuadrada de la aceleración donde no sé a
lo mejor la raíz cuadrada de un vector
sea sacar la raíz cuadrada en cada una
de las coordenadas verdad entonces
realmente estas fórmulas son muy
sencillas y eso es bastante interesante
ahora bien vamos a ver un pequeño
ejemplo por ejemplo digamos que tenemos
una fuerza una fuerza de 10 newtons ok
donde newton estamos pensando por
supuesto que son kilogramos por metro
sobre segundo al cuadrado los newtons
van a ser las unidades de la fuerza y
ahora tú te preguntarás oye pero si tú
me habías dicho que la fuerza es un
vector porque aquí es una cantidad
escalar y realmente es porque nosotros
estamos pensando que si estamos yendo
hacia la derecha es en sentido positivo
mientras que si estamos yendo a la
izquierda es en sentido negativo y esto
es digamos lo que le podría dar la
propiedad vectorial muy bien sobre
segundo al cuadrado
ahí está entonces si nosotros tenemos
una fuerza de 10 newtons qué pasaría si
yo tengo una masa un cuerpo cuya masa es
de 2 kilogramos
los kilogramos si yo tengo esta masa nos
preguntamos ahora cuál es la aceleración
que provoca esta fuerza vamos a ver
entonces lo que nosotros tenemos es
fuerza y masa y nosotros queremos
despejar la aceleración muy bien
nosotros queremos despejar la hacer la
aceleración entonces simplemente pasamos
dividiendo la la masa verdad es decir
tenemos 10 newtons 10 kilogramos por
metro sobre segundo al cuadrado y esto
es igual a 2 kilogramos que es nuestra
masa por la aceleración por la
aceleración muy bien entonces si
nosotros dividimos de ambos lados entre
2 kilogramos entre dos kilogramos de
ambos lados
burlados dividimos entre 2 kilogramos
del lado derecho esto inmediatamente se
cancela 10 dividido entre 2 nos da
exactamente 5 y los kilogramos se
cancelan con los kilogramos entonces lo
que obtenemos es que nuestra aceleración
es de 5 metros sobre segundo al cuadrado
lo cual nuestras unidades coinciden
perfectamente bien ok ahora por
diversión vamos a ver qué ocurre si
nosotros duplicamos la fuerza es decir
qué tal si tenemos 110 newtons y 120
newtons es decir qué tal si tenemos 20
kilogramos por metro sobre segundo al
cuadrado y esto va a ser igual a 2
kilogramos por la aceleración entonces
nuevamente dividimos entre dos
kilogramos de ambos lados y aquí se
cancelan 20 entre 2 nos da 10
gay y los kilogramos se cancelan y nos
queda 10 metros sobre segundo al
cuadrado es nuestra aceleración y cómo
puedes darte cuenta si nosotros
duplicamos la fuerza inmediatamente
tenemos el doble de la aceleración
verdad esto es lo que habíamos obtenido
anteriormente y esto es lo que ahora
obtuvimos entonces esto es lo que nos
está diciendo que estas cantidades son
proporcionales es decir si tú si duplica
la fuerza entonces vas a tener el doble
de aceleración ahora bien si nosotros
duplicamos la masa es decir que tengamos
un objeto mucho más con mucha más
materia digamos si duplicamos la masa
que es lo que ocurre por ejemplo aquí
vamos a verlo vamos a verlo en este de
aquí ok si nosotros duplicamos la masa
es decir que aquí apareciera 4
kilogramos entonces en realidad
dividimos entre 4 kilogramos y me
aparecen 20 entre 4 que son 5 verdad
entonces lo que ocurre es que si
duplicamos la masa entonces se reduce a
la mitad la fuerza verdad
y teníamos que era 10 si tenemos el
doble de masa tendremos que sería 555
metros sobre segundo cuadrado entonces
en resumen si uno duplica la masa
tendremos la mitad de la aceleración y
esto nos dice que mientras más masa haya
mayor fuerza hay que ejercer al objeto
para poder generar una aceleración sobre
él es decir es mucho más difícil cambiar
su velocidad constante